what I want to do in this video is think
a little bit more about how population's
can be regulated and broadly speaking we
can think of the regulation of
populations in two different categories
there's the regulation dependent on
density so density density dependent
regulation density dependent and then
there's the type of regulation that
isn't dependent on density so we could
call that density independent regulation
in the pendent independent regulation so
first let's think about density
dependent regulation and let me draw a
little chart here for it to help us
visualize that so let's say that that
axis is the population I'll say P for
population and let's say this axis is
time so T for time in previous videos we
talked about a population and I like to
use the example of rabbits how it could
grow exponentially so if it's just
growing a certain percent every month
that population will grow exponentially
but we can't expect that that will just
happen forever if rabbits just kept
growing on growing exponentially it
wouldn't take long for them to just
cover the surface of the earth and then
have it fill the universe if in some
ways they weren't limited by anything
but we know that they are limited by
things and so the environment only has a
certain amount of carrying capacity and
we'll think a little bit about this
carrying capacity in a second and what's
determining the carrying capacity and so
as the density of the rabbits in a
certain area get higher and higher and
higher well then the density dependent
we use a different color color the
density dependent factors start to play
the density dependent limiting factors
and what could be some of these density
dependent limiting factors that keep the
population from going dramatically above
the carrying capacity well the most
obvious one could be competition for
resources competition competition for
resources and the one that might come to
mind most clearly is food resources so
this
is actually a picture of Australia in
the mid-1800s and they had a bunny
population problem that the rabbits were
first introduced in order to have a
little bit of hunting but then they they
reproduce like rabbits and it was
estimated that at some point you had
over a billion rabbits that had
populated the country and that was you
might say oh how cute but it was a huge
problem they were they were eating all
of the the great they were eating they
were eating the the farmable they're
eating crops they were they were eating
the grass that you that other types of
livestock would graze on so it was a
huge infestation of rabbits and so you
could imagine one competition for
resources is just the grass itself in
this picture you can see that it's that
the land is barren maybe this happened
because the rabbits ate all of the
vegetation here so competition for
resources one type of resource could be
food
another type of resource could be could
be water there might only be so much
water to support organisms of a certain
kind and we're only you know here we
often talk about animals but it could be
plants or it could be bacteria it could
be all sorts of organisms that we're
talking about and if we're talking about
plants we could think about light you
could say well what limits having an
infinite number of plants in a certain
area well water will limit the nutrients
in the soil will limit but also access
to light you've seen pictures of a dense
canopy in a rainforest and the plants
are trying to seek out whatever gap in
the canopy they can find so that they
can get some access to that to that to
that light
now there's other examples and this
wouldn't apply as much to say plants but
the idea of shelter this might apply to
humans or to other types of animals that
maybe need shelter in order to hide or a
place to reproduce or whatever else so
at some point if the population density
gets too high in a certain region then
these things are going to limit how how
dense the population can get are frankly
just what the population actually is and
so that would lead once again we talked
about this in a previous video to this
logistic curve
over here where we just we don't we just
start approaching the carrying capacity
and it is possible that you could even
go above the carrying capacity and then
you're kind of this very unstable
situation and then something happens you
go below it then you go above it and
then below it and then something like
that but what are other density
dependent factors that we could think
about well another thing is if if you
are a predator when say the rabbits
become this dense it's much easier to
start to pick them off it's much easier
to get your lunch
and so predatory factors or we could say
predation predation once a population
gets large enough and dense enough it
might be the predator the Predators who
can say hey we can start it's way easier
for us to get our lunch now the other
thing that it might be a little less
obvious but when you have a high density
population and there's examples of this
in medieval times in Europe and and even
in modern times a day with with human
populations but this happens with all
organisms is that when you become a
dense population there's more
interaction there's more contact there's
more sharing of resources like water and
so disease and parasites becomes an
issue so let me write this down disease
disease and parasites can spread much
easier and they could they're much more
likely to start limiting the population
the thing that always comes to my mind
is the plague in medieval times where it
was very easy to spread from one human
to the next or frankly from rats to
humans and whatever else now the other
thing and this is maybe somewhat related
to everything else we've talked about is
waste accumulation so let me write this
right over here waste if you have a
really high density of population and
and the waste is just everywhere it
could poison the water it might poison
sources of food it was it might help the
spread of disease and parasites and once
again all of these things help define
what the carrying capacity how dense can
a population get in a certain region now
you might say well maybe they don't have
to stay in a region maybe they can go
and explore other places and that's
possible and that's been the story for
many different types of species let me
they are famous for when their
population gets dense in a certain area
groups of them start just running to
start exploring other areas sometimes
running in directions that are not that
good for them so all of these are
density dependent factors and a lot of
these as we as we just talked about you
could think of them as biotic factors
they're related to other living things
around the density independent factors
tend to be a biotic they tend to not be
related to living things so the most
common density independent factor is
natural disasters so natural natural
disaster we have a picture here of a
forest fire the deer population here
might not be in any way close to there
carrying capacity but despite that the
forest fire maybe might kill off a lot
of the deer other natural disasters you
could have a flood you could have a
tsunami
you could have a a meteorite coming from
from outer space that happened to the
dinosaurs to just knock out huge
populations and so density independent
factors you could have the population
growing and it's and it's just some
random point it just there's some
density independent factor there's a
forest fire there's a flood or something
else and then maybe the population grows
from there and eventually gets closer to
its carrying capacity who knows when the
density independent factors once again
it's not related to where we are on this
curve it could happen at any time and to
some degree they feel a little bit more
random now with all of this talk about
carrying capacities and and and the
different you know density dependent
factors you might be think well what
about human beings we we are foreshore
species and we we and and so the same
ideas apply to us and so is there a
natural carrying capacity for the
environments that we are in and there is
a famous philosopher scientist Thomas
Malthus and I have a whole video on him
but he hypothesized that humanity had a
very serious problem because we were our
populations were growing exponentially
so this is population this is time and
so he said look there's just a natural
carrying capacity for human beings
and as human beings just kept growing
exponentially we would hit we would hit
that that carrying capacity and the term
for that carrying capacity in the case
of human beings that Thomas Malthus that
up and there's a whole video on this is
the Malthusian limit and he hypothesized
that once we got once we cross it or
approached it there would be all sorts
of crises that once you're at this
carrying capacity there might not be
enough food and then there might be a
famine or the we we go across it and
then disease spreads a lot more and so
he was just applying these ideas of
density dependent factors to human
populations and said hey this is not
going to be pleasant for Humanity now
what's been interesting is that humanity
has found ways repeatedly of pushing up
the carrying capacity for us as a
species we've been able to do it frankly
through technology frankly finding ways
to grow food in denser and denser ways
ways to stave off disease ways to have
to get rid of waste and and sewage and
all of that so it's an interesting
philosophical question to say is there
ever going to be a point where human
being just hits this Malthusian where
human society hits this Malthusian limit
or are we always going to be able to
fend it off by just better and better
technology or maybe even just regulation
of the population itself so that we
don't you know where we just have
whatever birth control or family
planning or whatever it might be so that
we are less likely to hit some eventual
limit